las calles de rangún vuelven a pintarse
de rojo este domingo manifestantes
abanderando el color de la liga nacional
para la democracia el partido de la
nobel de paz encarcelada auctions aquí
salieron desde varios puntos de la
ciudad hasta concentrarse cerca de la
pagoda azul el monumento más
representativo del país
[Aplausos]
decidí resistir a la dictadura militar
en 2021 para no tener que vivir como en
hemos tomado una decisión vamos a luchar
hasta el final con nuestras vidas por
nuestra generación tenemos que trabajar
por la próxima generación para conseguir
la democracia para ellos si queremos
acabar con esa dictadura militar
desde el golpe militar del lunes primero
de febrero al menos 152 personas
continúan detenidas entre ellas dos
sentenciados a dos años de cárcel por
cargos que no han sido precisados
mientras que las autoridades han dejado
en libertad a otras doce personas que
habían sido detenidas durante el golpe
mientras tanto el país recuperó al menos
temporalmente la producción de internet
de este domingo bloquearán durante más
de 24 horas por el gobierno militar los
servicios de internet de telenor ya se
han restablecido en mi amar
y aunque sigue vigente la censura
ordenada por los uniformados contra
twitter y facebook muchos usuarios
logran burlar las restricciones a través
de redes privadas virtuales